Optimal at this altitude,
I can run flat out for a half mile before my hands start shaking familiar.
I'm a cybernetic organism living tissue.
Books.
I've loved on the Tim Ferriss show is exclusively brought to you by audible.
There couldn't be a better sponsor for this series.
My dear listeners and readers I've used audible for so many years,
as long as I can remember. I love it.
Audible has the largest selection of audio books on the planet.
I listen when I'm taking walks. I listen while I'm cooking.
I listen whenever I can. And if you're looking for a place to start,
I can recommend three of my favorites.
The first is the Tao of Seneca by Seneca.
If you want to hear my favorite letters of all time touches on stoic philosophy,
calmness under duress, et cetera.
The next is the graveyard book by Neil Gaiman,
G a I M a N one of my favorites,
even if you're a nonfiction purist,
this is the fiction book that you need to listen to.
Neo also has perhaps the most calming voice of all time and third,
Greg McKeown's essential ism subtitle.
The disciplined pursuit of less.
This is one of my favorite books of the past few years combines very well with
the 80 20 principle, but more on audible every month.
Audible members get one credit for any audio book on the site,
plus a choice of multiple audible originals from a rotating selection.
They also get access to daily news digests from the likes of the New York times
wall street journal and the Washington post as well as guided meditation
programs. And here are some other amazing audible features.
And I use a bunch of these. You can download titles and listen offline anytime,
anywhere I use this feature,
even when I could get access, I'll put my phone on say airplane mode,
because I don't want to get bothered with notifications.
And I'm taking a walk to clear my head and you can listen to titles offline in a
case like that or on a plane or whatever.
Obviously I'm not flying much these days.
The app is free and can be installed on all smartphones and tablets.
You can listen across devices without losing your spot.
And whisper sync is another feature I use quite a lot.
I love reading my Kindle in bed. For instance,
then picking up at the same exact spot where I left off.
When I go walking and listening to the next day,
Kindle and audio versions can be sinked up automatically. It's just amazing.
And if you can't decide what to listen to, don't sweat it.
You don't have to rush.
You can keep your credits for up to a year and use them for instance,
to binge on a whole series. If you like audible offers just about everything.
Podcasts, guided wellness programs, theatrical performances, alias comedy,
and audible originals. You won't find anywhere else.
And right now audible is offering you guys.
That's Tim Ferriss show listeners a free audio book with a 30 day trial
membership. And, uh, again, my list, if you want to check them out,
the Tao of Seneca, the graveyard book, essential ism,
those are just three there's so many good ones out there.
Just go to audible.com/tim and browse the unmatched
selection of audio programs. Then download your free title and start listening.
It's that easy? Just check it out.
Go to audible.com/tim or text Tim T I M
to 500, 500 to get started today. Check it out.
audible.com/tim.
Hello.
Boys and girls, ladies and germs. This is Tim Ferriss.
Welcome to another episode of the Tim Ferriss show,
where it is usually my job to sit down with world-class performers of all
different types, startup founders, investors, chess champions, Olympic athletes,
you name it to tease out that habits that you can apply in your own lives.
This episode, however,
is an experiment and part of a short form series that I'm doing simply
called books. I've loved. I've invited some amazing past guests,
close friends and new faces to share their favorite books.
Describe their favorite books. The books that have influenced them,
changed them, transform them for the better.
And I hope you pick up one or two new mentors in the form of books from this new
series and apply the lessons in your own life.
I had a lot of fun putting this together,
inviting these people to participate and have learned so, so much myself.
I hope that is also the case for you. Please enjoy.
Thanks, Tim,
for having me back to talk about some of my favorite books and I wanted to do
something different today,
which is I wanted to recommend some books that I've never recommended before on
this podcast.
And that I haven't heard other people recommending things that people may not
know about.
I want to turn people onto some new staff that's like so central to me.
So my criteria were,
what are the books where I've underlined the most amount of things,
some of these books that I'm going to recommend,
I literally have underlining or marks on every single page that I have a
kind of involved system. I use to Mark up books,
depending on the residents of the idea and different things going on in the
book. The second thing is brought together.
These books sort of encompass like the
body of what I think right now,
the kinds of things that I write about and post on Instagram and teach and
coach, and have had so much value in my life and change them.
And I'm going to walk you into them for,
let's say the simplest book to the most complex from one
that's just so easy to read to one, that's almost like a textbook.
So if you're into these, start at the beginning and see how far along you get.
I love all of these,
and they're really great on the path to understanding yourself and who you
are and the obstacles that get in your way and where you
self-sabotage and your relationships, and ultimately real freedom.
The first author, Cheri Huber. And I wanted to tell you about her past,
but I looked it up online and I can't find anything there.
So I don't know if it's public, but as a child,
Sherry probably faced one of the worst traumas a young person can
ever go through and she not only survived it.
She became a Buddhist monk and of all the people I've ever met in
my life. I think she's one of the most centered, wise,
powerful presences I've ever been around.
There's just something about her that I can, my, I would like to get to one day.
I really would. She writes tons of books. I'd love to read every one.
And her books are very simply written. There's just distilled to pure wisdom.
Almost like a wise mentor is giving you the advice there.
Aren't like supporting arguments and footnotes and research studies is
just like the wisdom from high on the mountain.
It's also written a unique font where part of the story and the power and the
impact of the words is done through the font and style of writing,
changing as well as the illustrations by June Shriver,
or it could be shiver the illustrator in the book.
So really look through all our books and read anything.
But I'll share with you the two that have had the biggest impact on me.
Actually, the only two I've read, I would do want to read the rest,
but I started with the fear book and fear book is so powerful because so many of
us have a certain area where fear and doubt
and uncertainty get in our way.
And the book walks you through the idea of, of,
of how to embrace them and move beyond them.
And often it's very counter-intuitive, but so true.
I highly recommend this for dealing with it and want to go read you one quote
from it. I'm going to read a couple of quotes from it.
And her basic idea is that moving toward your fears and getting past them is the
path to freedom. And I love this part in her books, by the way,
are very short, 150 pages at most. She writes,
if you no longer believe what fear tells you, you will live.
And it will not.
That is a point on the spiritual journey that almost nobody gets past when that
terrorizes,
when it gets backed into a corner and some matter of its survival or yours,
almost nobody has the required combination of courage, desperation,
willingness to stand up to it.
When this force in you that is controlled and motivated you all your life is
screaming. If you do that, you're going to die.
Very few people are going to say, well, I just need to find out if that is true.
Or if that is so she writes,
that's why it's so important to remember that projection is going on.
What's being screamed on a paraphrase a little too.
So it kind of sinks in what's really being screamed here is if you stay with
this fear, I will die.
The fear the Eagle will die and that's true. It will die.
It's life is your death. It's death is your life.
So good.
It's really about letting go of the stuff that holds you back that you're so
attached to and just isn't serving you and is keeping you from being free and
keeping it from being yourself.
And here's one last little bit from the book you can do right now, now, so good.
Do something you fear not to conquer the fear,
not to accomplish a task, but to familiarize yourself with the process,
with which fear protects itself to demystify it. And I love this.
I've said in this podcast before become a scientist of your own lows and this
the same become a scientist of fear. It's,
it's almost like I call it false survival mode.
There's so many things that we think are survival threats,
and we treat them like survival threats and we go start fighting like our life
in danger when it isn't. So it's a great demystifying empowering book.
It's called the fear book. The other book of Sherry hubris,
I recommended I'm pulling it out now,
as we speak is be the person you want to find relationship and self discovery.
And the title kind of says it all.
And I love this book because it's actually my philosophy on relationships,
which is if you want to meet a better person, then become a better person.
And this is like this beautiful book that really elegantly sort of
weans us away from these crazy relationship myths we have and these expectations
of other partners. And it begins by really boldly saying,
there's this book is about you taking 100% responsibility for yourself
all the time. And, uh,
and I really think of everybody can read this book and really live by it.
Things would go so much better if it's about things that we're going to get into
later and with the next set of books, about how much, uh,
of our childhood sort of stories,
we ended up playing out on our partner. And then again,
I'm just gonna read one part, then we'll move on. I mean,
this book is so good that instead of underlining lines,
I've literally like marked entire pages. So these are two of the pages.
And again, it flies by it's a short book, the sad, strange,
unfortunate, dysfunctional part of life, by the way.
So I'm going to read this part. I'm going to paraphrase a couple of bits,
just so it makes sense out of context, the sad, strange, unfortunate,
dysfunctional part of life is that as adults, most of us,
I was still trying to survive childhood.
So I have become the person I believed as a child.
I needed to become in order to make it through adulthood, diamond adult,
and an intimate relationship. And I'm suffering. This is traumatic.
I have picked consciously or not someone who's going to relive parts of my
childhood with me. He's going to play the parts opposite me.
Someone else did back then.
I'm going to suffer in the same way I did as a child.
And I'm going to use the same survival mechanisms and right
there is literally,
it doesn't matter what recurring problem we're having a relationship.
That is the reason why, and this book gets you past them. I love it.
Highly recommended next author. So we're going to move sort of one level up on,
I don't want to say like difficult to read or advancement of concepts,
but also very, very accessible books, thereby Pia Mellody,
I'm going to recommend two books and we'll start with facing co-dependence and
co-dependence is a word that's used a lot, but really rarely understood.
And this book isn't just about relationships for me,
what it is is it presents a model of trauma.
That to me has been key to understanding my life and to helping
others and is really life-changing. And here's,
what's fascinating about PML study. She doesn't do Ted talks,
at least as far as I know, she doesn't have a big social media presence.
If one at all, she doesn't even have a Wikipedia entry. She was,
I believe a nurse at a inpatient sort of rehab facility called the Meadows and
started to develop her own system based on a number of different therapies and
tools. And it's really powerful if I was to say, Hey,
if you really want to change what a modality, even though I hate that word,
what modalities should do? Should you follow, I'd say,
check into PML studies work, uh,
what's called pit post induction therapy. I think that's what it's called,
what it stands for,
but her whole idea is your childhood is a hypnotic induction.
You're being sort of indoctrinated.
It's like a cult and you're then to be unbrainwashing and hypnotized
is start living your true and free life.
Let an elegant idea the great part about facing co-dependence besides his
exploration of what codependency is, why it happens, how it happens, uh,
the signs, the patterns,
there's also a breakdown in the end of how she defines trauma.
And it's a way to sort of,
self-diagnose a trauma and I'm just going to check out the contents right here.
To me as a new parent is also a parenting book.
She talks about the nature of a child, how a child has these rights.
And I've thought about it with my child, has I've raised him to be spontaneous,
to be protected, to be. And I love this line perfectly imperfect.
In other words, some parents expect their child to be perfect.
And that's sort of a form of trauma when they're not allowed to make mistakes or
learn from their mistakes or do things that are sort of age appropriate.
And then she talks about abuse, generational abuse,
and then breaks down trauma to these different categories of physical abuse,
sexual abuse, emotional abuse, intellectual abuse, spiritual abuse.
And the main thing about these is it sounds obvious when you read it,
she defines abuse as anytime a child has a dependency need. That's not met.
That creates abuse. So a quick example of spiritual abuse,
I see many with it is when a parent has to always be right.
The parents always right. They can never be wrong. They can never be corrected.
And she sees that as a form of spiritual abuse because the parents blame
God, the parent becomes the child's higher power and it creates such a deep
insecurity on the part of the child in terms of their reality. In fact,
I find these people often resistant to work with because they feel like to say
anything negative about their parent is like blaspheming. God, it's fascinating.
So I highly recommend it the second book to read next,
and this one is more about relationships, but I love it.
Definitely something that's put a lot of value in my life in terms of breaking
some patterns is called facing love addiction.
And it's really about the love addict and the love avoidance.
And this is probably like probably 75% of relationships to some degree.
I'm just throwing that out ballpark.
But what happens is one person in a relationship is more needy and one
person is a more resentful and,
uh, it doesn't begin that way.
It begins in this flowering of love and projection.
And then eventually this pattern plays out where one person needs more.
The other person wants to give less and less.
The other person gives the more the other person needs.
And there's this neediness resentment pattern that eventually plays out and
blows up in negative ways. Often,
sometimes when I know people who have been their partners,
but having a fare for a long time and they never saw it,
they're often in a haze of love addiction,
where they're holding onto this fantasy. It's a powerful book.
I love these both really read these multiple times and you'll have
an understanding of the matrix of how relationships work as PML,
body facing co-dependence and facing levitation.
So the next book is not for everyone,
but it's for a certain percentage of people here I'm among it's a target
audience. And I didn't think I was a monster target audience.
When I first heard about it as called silently seduced is by
Kenneth Adams. And it's related to the PML Eddie books. I mentioned earlier.
And specifically for those who've experienced in measurement and measurement is
not a word that's often used. So I'm going to explain it super quickly.
It's the opposite of abandonment. So abandonment, as we all know,
is a parent is somehow not meeting a child's needs, whether emotional,
physical protection being absent,
whatever it may be in measurement is when a child is meeting a
parent's needs. And,
and we don't talk about it because abandonment is disempowering.
You feel disempowered, helpless, vulnerable,
no one there in measurement is falsely empowering. You feel as a child,
like you have power because you're there for your parents,
a parent who lives for a child who needs the child's accomplishments to make up
their own accomplishments, who has apparent with tons of anxiety,
needs to over-control the child, a parent who's lonely, or has a bad marriage,
or is going through a divorce and is using the child for their own narcissistic
reasons or to get back at the parent or just because they have,
nobody has talked to,
there are so many ways that a measurement works and here's a,
here's a little rule of thumb that abandonment,
you feel bad about yourself with inmeshment it's only when you feel sorry for
the parent. So if you ever,
there's a moment where he felt sad or sorry for your parent,
that probably was a measurement going on.
I remember interviewing Jay Leno and talking about comedy and he became a
comedian because his mom was depressed and he was always trying to cheer her up.
That's a measurement and silently seduced deals with a form of enmeshment that
they call shockingly emotional incest. I remember when I booked the truth,
came out, actually wrote an editorial for New York times on emotional incest.
And it wasn't printed. That's such a shocking term.
It shocked me when it was used to diagnose me.
But what it is is it's when a child is used not sexually by the parent,
when a child used emotionally by the parent becomes an emotional partner to
them. And often it's a parent,
who's in a troubled relationship who makes the child, their emotional partner.
As my mom, 100% did with me.
She'd sit there in my room and talk to him about my father.
And I remember she actually said,
Neil never grew up to make anyone as miserable as your father makes me,
which really, really, uh, uh, messed up my relationships for awhile.
I felt like somebody was sad or wasn't, wasn't happy.
I would just sort of end the relationship.
So what happens with people who are in meshed is they want love.
They want relationships.
Then they get in a relationship and they feel suffocated.
They feel trapped and they sabotage it or want to get out of it. Somehow,
this is crazy intimacy attraction than avoidance pattern usually.
And it's a great book about it. It walks you through,
it explains the cases and it gives you steps to break the pattern.
So highly recommended silently seduced by Kenneth Adams.
If this is appropriate to you or 70 data in the past two or someone you care
about, it's a good gift. I'd definitely given at least a hundred of these away.
I love this next author. I'm just going to start with this.
He meaning the type of man he's talking about will believe that his
masculinity is proved by betting women driving a high powered car or making
lots of money underneath. He knows the truth, of course,
and he is desperately afraid of being found out.
He believes himself an impostor in the company of men.
And in this era, in our society,
when we're trying to sort of look at the roles,
men play at a mass, they were to have a sort of better, healthier society.
I highly recommend this book.
It's another one that I've given this at this point,
probably like more than a hundred copies away, uh,
it's called under and shadow the wounding and healing of men by James Hollis
and Jamie Hollis is a youngian psychoanalyst. It amazing author.
I actually loved his books so much.
I hadn't been my therapist for awhile and was literally like taking a college
class. It's so good. It's not the easiest book to make it through,
but it's so dense with meaning with historical example, with amazing quotes.
And it really looks at a deep mythical,
psychological level of the struggles that the modern sort of man faces and
attempts to put a framework around it.
That's so wonderfully full of wisdom.
And I really don't see the sort of addressed a lot in a, in a helpful,
useful non-shared gaming, uh,
self understanding ending way. I was looking for another quote,
but I stumbled across this. I literally have something underlined on every page.
What father can not access in himself can not be passed onto his son.
Such a good to think about it for the parents out there like myself. So good.
I'm going to read a little part. I'm literally just turning a random page.
There's so much in here. It's just worth it. We're hearing all the time.
He writes as Joseph Campbell expressed it.
One can spend one's whole life climbing the ladder only to realize that it's
been placed against the wrong wall for men to begin the process of healing.
They must first risk being honest with themselves,
along the feelings they think they can't afford.
They must admit they're not happy in spite of what they've achieved.
They must admit they do not know who they are,
what they must do to save themselves.
They must overcome the fear that blocks such thinking the fear that they will
have to change their lives. If the emotional cat is let out of the bag.
And ultimately it's a book about set of self-examination and making sure you're
not just running on these preset tracks,
that the culture has given you and really living out what's important to you,
or as Hala says it. And we'll end the description of the book with this.
The crux of the middle passage is the requirements that a man,
whatever his age or station pull out of his reflexive behaviors and attitudes
radically,
re-examine his life at risk living out the thunderous imperatives of his soul.
So good, highly recommended. So what did James Hollis has?
Central ideas is we have these two that we have these two fantastic quest we go
on in our lives. One is the fantasy day mortality,
and the other one is a fantasy of the magical other.
And the latter is the heart of his other book that I love,
which is the Eden project. And let me get the subtitle here,
the Eden project in search of a magical other, uh,
kind of like the Cheri Huber book. He just cuts to the core of it.
I'm going to look right now with one of my favorite quotes from it.
It's so good. It's so good.
Being in an intimate relationship is a bit like asking someone to join hands
with us, but only after walking across a field in which we have planted minds
and another great quote. And I think this just captures the book he writes.
The best thing we can do for our relationships with others is to render our
relationship to ourselves more conscious.
This is not a narcissistic activity. In fact,
it will prove to be the most loving thing we can do for the other.
The greatest gift to others is our own best selves.
That's paradoxically. If we are to serve relationship well,
we are obliged to affirm our individual journey. It's so good.
And yes, it's just like the wisdom, the Sherry humor book.
I want to love about all these books,
whether it's sort of PML coming from inpatient addiction rehab,
or it's James Hollis coming from young or Cheri
Huber coming from Buddhism. It's the exact same wisdom.
So if you read all these books, if you put them all together,
they're all telling the same thing. So go do it.
Hey guys, this is Tim again, just a few more things before you take off.
Number one, this is five bullet Friday.
Do you want to get a short email from me?
Would you enjoy getting a short email from me every Friday that provides a
little more of fun before the weekend and five bullet Friday is a very short
email where I share the coolest things I've found or that I've been pondering
over the week.
That could include favorite new albums that I've discovered it could include
gizmos and gadgets and all sorts of weird that I've somehow dug up in the, uh,
the world of the esoteric as I do.
It could include favorite articles that I've read and that I've shared
with my close friends, for instance. And it's very short.
It's just a little tiny bite of goodness before you head off for the weekend.
So if you want to receive that, check it out,
just go to four-hour work week.com that's four hour work week.com all spelled
out and just drop in your email and you will get the very next one.
And if you sign up.
[Inaudible].